[Music]
i'm jimmy yukis in alhambra california
near los angeles school is back in
session but the more than 500 students
who attend this elementary school
are now learning from home fifth grader
riley franco is one of at least 10
million kids now taking classes online
this fall
and while her school provided things
like wi-fi hotspots and computers
it's proving to be a challenging time
for families like riley's grandmother
josie
her legal guardian what's been the
hardest part i'm not
technology savvy at all and if i wasn't
for riley
i wouldn't know how to do it what do you
miss most about school
being with my friends what's been the
hardest thing you think for your grandma
keep on waking me up and making sure
that i'm never late how has she been
with the computer
the internet goes off and on and off and
on and we can't control it i'm always
like grandma the thing goes off and she
was like
she's always stressed out because of
that
how do you feel this is gonna work out
this is our only
option that we have right now so i think
this year will be
a lot better going into the second phase
i see riley
eager to learn and to listen to her
teacher
there's still no timetable as to when
kids will return to the classroom
for cbs this morning jamie yukas
alhambra california
thank you jamie yukas